[Music]
China a land of rich history culture and
now Rory economic success arguably the
most people moving into higher standards
of living I just came back from doing
interviews in China and my mind was
blown the hospitality was incredible the
geography was gorgeous
the technology was cutting-edge people
carrying a deep meaning and purpose in
life the spirit of China has a profound
connection to Confucianism and Daoism
which feels like it permeates all man
society ethics nature and the universe
nighttime dancing was common in plazas
and outside train stations exercise
equipment was built into parks five six
okay so this is very good this is very
good that you have these lists because
this is one of the most I surrounded
myself mostly with leadership and
students of pecking University in
Beijing and Westlake University in
Hangzhou have you ever noticed how
Harvard and MIT are a couple kilometers
from each other in Cambridge
Massachusetts pecking and Ching hua
University are just like that as they
are topped to your schools in China and
geographically close in Beijing I'm
keeping a close eye on funnels like
these for the world's most brilliant
young my
I was impressed by how focused these
schools are on fundamental science many
are trying to push the edges of fields
like physics math biology chemistry
neuroscience computer science and
translate their work to real-world
applications that benefit society at
large these schools have a very rigorous
entrance testing system called the
Gaucho many are the only child in their
families representing two parents and
four grandparents many following the
global trend of moving from rural to
metro areas for opportunities the
hierarchical pressure to succeed on
behalf of the family is crucial
similarly with finding a great career
spouse and housing continuing the cycle
of life this was a big change in pace
from the more laid-back entrepreneurial
spirit of California at times it felt
like the Chinese socioeconomic machinery
was just picking up steam while the USA
was getting overly comfortable the USA
is a melting pot of diverse cultures
from around the world while China is
quite homogeneous other big differences
are how old China is the center of
Beijing has the Forbidden City which for
almost 500 years served as the home of
Emperor's and the political center of
the Chinese government
given China's massive population their
focus on frictionless transportation has
been one of their biggest payoffs the
high-speed rail reaches speeds over 300
kilometers an hour almost 190 miles per
hour transiting people efficiently
between major cities okay so my QR code
on what app is this the transit Chinese
another major technology difference was
their adaptation of quick response QR
codes which people use to scan for
adding each other as contacts paying
vendors basically QR codes are
everywhere their focus on facial
recognition technology was fascinating
students at Peking University were using
their faces to enter the campus one of
the most interesting takeaways from this
entire video is the Great Firewall of
China set up over 20 years ago by
blocking domestic access to foreign
information sources China experienced a
forcing function which nurtured their
domestic internet economy this created
some of the most important internet
companies that every person should be
aware of Alibaba $0.10 Baidu
JD calm Sina bike dance Billy Billy net
ease DeeDee Xiaomi Huawei BYD
DJI Juhu and many more if you haven't
heard of these companies take the time
to research each of them it would be
like if someone had never heard of
Google Apple Amazon Microsoft Facebook
LinkedIn Twitter Netflix uber Tesla its
[Music]
this roaring economic success is helping
China clean up their air pollution
Electrify their transit modernize their
city centers care more for recycling and
composting and just build a ridiculous
amount of infrastructure but nothing in
the world right now compares to the belt
and Road initiative which has been
called the greatest economic development
project of the 21st century over the
next 30 years China is planning to make
massive investments in infrastructure
development in over 150 countries in the
world again this is something you
absolutely must familiarize yourself
with China's focus on running these
interesting experiments seems
unparalleled the last one I will list is
Westlake University in Hangzhou where we
did our second round of partnership
interviews they are founded with the
vision of becoming a world-class
research institution that is tackling
immense challenges like the United
Nations sustainable development goals
they are conducting some of the most
cutting-edge science I've ever seen in
my life and attracting some of the
world's most brilliant minds to China to
me it looks like the blueprint of
public-private partnerships that can
hopefully be replicated around the world
to refocus civilization on advancing
science technology and philosophy to the
next levels
but my biggest takeaway is I urge you to
travel to China experience their rich
history culture and roaring economic
success make friends there and urge them
to travel to the United States Travel
eradicate xenophobia bigotry and narrow
mindedness plus there is a lot that the
two countries can do to learn from each
other
[Music]